[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right, welcome
back to 006 Data Structures.
Today, we're going to
cover a different kind
of tree-like data structure
called a heap-- a binary heap.
It's going to let us solve
sorting problem in a new way.
Let me first remind
you of a portion--
the problem we're going
to be solving today
is called priority queue.
This is the interface.
We'll see several
data structures,
but one main data
structure for today.
And this is a subset
of the set interface.
And subsets are interesting
because, potentially, we
can solve them better,
faster, simpler, something.
And so you'll recognize--
you should recognize
all of these operations,
except we didn't normally
highlight the max operation.
So here, we're interested
in storing a bunch of items.
They have keys which we
think of as priorities.
And we want to be able to
identify the maximum priority
item in our set and remove it.
And so there's lots of
motivations for this.
Maybe you have a router,
packets going into the router.
They have different
priorities assigned to them.
You want to route the
highest priority first.
Or you have processes
on your computer trying
to run on your single
threaded-- single core,
and you've got to choose
which one to run next.
And you usually run higher
priority processes first.
Or you're trying to simulate
a system where events happen
at different times,
and you want to process
the next event ordered by time.
All of these are examples of
the priority queue interface.
We'll even see applications
within this class
when we get to graph algorithms.
But the main two things we
want to be able to support
are inserting an item,
which includes a key,
and leading the maximum
item, and also returning it
at the same time.
We'll also talk some about being
able to build the structure
faster than just inserting it.
But of course, we
could implement
build by starting empty
and repeatedly inserting.
And also the complexity
of just finding the max
without deleting it, this you
could simulate with these two
operations by deleting the
max and then reinserting it,
which works.
But often, we can do faster.
But the two key, main operations
are insert and delete max.
And we're going to see a few
data structures to do this.
Any suggestions among
the data structures
we've seen in this class?
What should we use to solve
priority queue interface?
Many possible answers.
AUDIENCE: Sequence AVL?
ERIK DEMAINE: Sequence AVL?
Ooh, that's interesting!
Sequence AVL is a good answer,
but maybe the fancier version.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Set AVL?
ERIK DEMAINE: Set
AVL sounds good.
Set AVL supports these
operations and many more.
All in log n time except for
build, which takes n log n time
because you have to sort first.
So set AVL a good
way to do this.
We'll come back to your
sequence AVL idea later.
This gets log n for operation.
Great.
I mean, this is--
set AVL is our most
powerful data structure.
It does all the operations we
care about on the set side.
And the sequence AVL
does all the operations
on the sequence side.
But note that this is
a set, not a sequence.
We care about keys.
There are hacks to get around
that with sequence AVLs,
but let's do that later.
So great, if we wanted
to, for example,
speed up find_max in a set AVL.
We could add augmentation.
We could-- remember subtree
property augmentations?
We can use that to get
constant time find_max
by storing in every node
the maximum key item
within the subtree.
And that's a subtree property.
It's one we
mentioned last class.
So we could even improve
that to cut some time.
Great.
So we're done.
End of lecture.
[CHUCKLES] In some
sense, that's true.
But what we're
going to see today
is another data structure
called a binary heap,
which is, in some sense, a
simplification of set AVL.
It achieves basically
the same time bounds.
Build will be faster
by a log factor.
But that's not the main
reason we care about them.
The main advantage is
that they're simpler
and they give us an
in-place sorting algorithm.
So I have up here
three of the operations
I've been talking about--
build, insert, and delete_max.
So we have set AVL trees there--
n log n build, log n insert,
log n delete.
So along the way to our heap, I
want to mention two other data
structures.
One is a dynamic
but unsorted array.
And the other is a
dynamic sorted array.
These are simpler
data structures
we've talked about
many times before.
And they're useful kind
of motivations for getting
started, because a heap is going
to be built on top of arrays
instead of--
well, it's sort of a fusion
between arrays and trees.
So if I have an unsorted
array, this is very easy
to insert into, right?
I just append to the end.
This is what we
called insert last.
So insert is fast,
constant amortized.
We might have to
resize the array,
but so that's the
amortized part.
But delete max is slow.
In an unsorted array, I don't
know where the maximum is.
So I have to scan
through the whole array.
So I scan through
the array, identify
that the max is somewhere
in the middle, and then,
if I want to delete it--
I want to delete that
maximum element, well,
in a dynamic array,
all I can really
do is delete the last
element efficiently.
So I could, for example, swap
it with the last element.
So I take this element
and put it here, and then
delete the last element in that
array, which is pop in Python
or delete_last in our world.
So overall, this is
linear time, which is bad.
But I wanted to highlight
exactly how it's
done for a reason we'll
get to in a moment.
A sorted array is
sort of the reverse.
It's very easy to find the max.
Where is it?
At the end.
delete_max, the maximum element
is always the last element
in a increasing sorted array.
I guess that's constant
amortized, because then I
have to delete it, which
may incur resizing.
Insert, though, is
going to be linear,
because maybe I can
binary search to find
where the added item belongs.
Let's say I just
added this item here.
I could binary
search to find it,
but then I'm going to
have to do a big shift.
So I might as well
just swap repeatedly
until I find the position
where the added item x belongs.
And now I've restored
sorted order.
That takes linear
time, which is bad.
And what we want is somehow
the best of these two worlds.
Insert is fast for array.
Delete is fast for
a sorted array.
We can't get constant
time for both.
But we can get log
n time for both.
We already know how
with set AVL trees.
But we're going to see a
different way to do it today.
And the main motivation for
a different way to do this
is sorting.
So I want to define a
priority queue sort.
So given any data structure
that implements a priority queue
interface, in particular
insert and delete_max,
I can make a sorting algorithm.
What do I do?
Insert all the items,
delete all the items.
But because when I delete them
they come out largest first,
I get them in
reverse sorted order.
Then I could reverse in linear
time and I've sorted my items.
So we can insert (x) for
x in A, or (build(A)),
and then repeatedly delete_max.
How much time does
this algorithm take?
I'm going to introduce
some notation here.
It takes however long it
takes to build n items,
call that T sub build (n) plus--
sorry-- plus n times the
time to do a delete_max.
Or we can write
this as n times time
to do an insert, plus
time to do a delete_max.
So I'm using these T functions
to just abstract what
are the running times provided
by my data structure that
implements this interface.
Interface says
what's correct is,
and these T functions give
me my performance bounds.
So if I plug in each of
these data structures,
I get a sorting algorithm.
I get AVL sort,
I get array sort,
I get assorted array sort.
What do those look like?
It turns out many of
these are familiar.
So set AVLs take
log n per operation.
So we get an n log n sorting
algorithm out of them, which
is insert all of the
items into the AVL tree.
I don't want to use AVL build
because that uses sort, and not
allowed to sort in
order to implement sort.
But we saw how to
insert into an AVL tree
and keep the thing balanced.
So that takes log n each.
And then we can find the
max, delete it, rebalance,
and so on.
Total time will be n log n.
This is an algorithm
we call AVL sort.
It's a bit complicated, because
AVL trees are complicated.
But it gives us optimal
comparison bound and log n.
Now, what about array sort?
So suppose I use
an unsorted array.
I insert the item.
So if I insert the items--
so I'm doing all the insertions
here before all the deletions.
So what's going to happen
is I just insert the items
in the original array order.
In other words, I
just take the array.
And then what I do is repeatedly
extract the maximum item
by searching for it, moving
it to the end of the array,
and then repeating that process.
That sound familiar?
That's selection sort
from lecture three.
So this-- arrays give
us selection sort.
This is a new way
to think about what
we were doing way back then.
With a sorted array,
what are we doing?
We insert all the items.
That's actually where all
the work happens, because we
maintain the sorted array.
So we start with an empty array.
It's sorted.
We add an item.
OK, it's still sorted.
We add a second
item, and we swap
if we need to in order to sort.
In general, when we add an
item, we swap it to the left
until it's sorted again.
That is insertion sort.
Kind of cool, this is a unifying
framework for three sorting
algorithms that we saw before.
We didn't actually talk
about AVL sort last time,
but it was in the notes.
And so that is the right
part of this table.
So of course, these array data
structures are not efficient.
They take linear time for
some of the operations.
So the sorting algorithms
are not efficient.
But they're ones
we've seen before,
so it's neat to see
how they fit in here.
They had the-- selection
sort and insertion
sort had the advantage
that they were in place.
You just needed a constant
number of pointers or indices
beyond the array itself.
So they're very space efficient.
So that was a plus for them.
But they take n squared
time, so you should never
use them, except for n,
at most, 100 or something.
AVL tree sort is great and then
it gets n log n time, probably
more complicated than
merge sort and you
could stick to merge sort.
But neither merge sort nor set
AVL tree sort are in place.
And so the goal
of today is to get
the best of all those
worlds in sorting
to get n log n
comparisons, which
is optimal in the
comparison model,
but get it to be in place.
And that's what we're going
to get with binary heaps.
We're going to design
a data structure that
happens to build a little
bit faster-- as I mentioned,
linear time building.
So it's not representing a
sorted order in the same way
that AVL trees are.
But it will be
kind of tree-based.
It will also be array-based.
We're going to get logarithmic
time for insert and delete_max.
It happens to be amortized,
because we use arrays.
But the key thing is that it's
an in-place data structure.
It only consists of
an array of the items.
And so, when we plug it
into our sorting algorithm--
priority queue sort or
generic sorting algorithm--
not only do we get
n log n performance,
but we also get an
in-place sorting algorithm.
This will be our first
and only-- to this class--
n log n in-place
sorting algorithm.
Cool.
That's the goal.
Let's do it.
So what we're going to do,
because we're in place,
basically we have to have an
array storing our end items.
That's sort of the
definition of in-place,
just using n slots
of memory exactly
the size of the number of
items in our structure.
But we're obviously not going
to use a regular unsorted array
or a regular sorted array.
We're going to use
array just as sort
of the underlying technology
for how things are stored.
But we'd really like
logarithmic performance, which
should make you think tree.
Only way to get a log is the
binary tree, more or less.
So somehow, we want to
embed a tree into an array.
Let me grab an example.
Let me draw a tree.
If I got to choose
any old tree I want,
I would choose a tree that's
basically perfectly balanced.
Perfectly balanced would
be like this, where--
what's the property?
That I have all
of these levels--
all of these depths are
completely filled with nodes.
This is depth 0.
Remember, this is depth 1, this
is depth 2, this is depth 3.
So what I'd really like
is to have 2 to the i
nodes at depth i.
That would be a
perfect binary tree.
But that only works when n is 1
less than a power of 2, right?
I can't always achieve
that for any n.
And so the next best
thing I could hope for
is 2 to the i at
nodes at depth i
until the very last
i-- the largest depth.
And in that level, I'm still
going to restrict things.
I'm going to force
all of the nodes
to be as far left as possible.
So I want to say, except at
max depth where nodes are--
I'll call them left justified.
And these two
properties together
is what I call a
complete binary tree.
Why is this interesting?
Because I claim I can represent
a tree like this as an array.
I've narrowed things down enough
that I can draw an array down
here.
And what I'm going to
do is write these nodes
in depth order.
So I write A first,
because that's step 0.
Then B, C, that's step 1.
Then, well, they're
alphabetical.
I made it that way.
D, E, F, G is depth 2.
And then H, I, J is step 3.
This is very different from
traversal order of a tree.
Traversal order would have
been H, D, I, B, J, E, A, F, C,
G, OK?
But this is what we
might call depth order,
do the lowest
depth nodes first--
very different way to lay things
out or to linearize our data.
And this is what a heap
is going to look like.
So the cool thing is,
between complete binary
trees and arrays is a bijection.
For every array, there's a
unique complete binary tree.
And for every complete binary
tree, there's a unique array.
Why?
Because the complete
constraint forces
everything-- forces my hand.
There's only-- if I
give you a number n,
there is one tree
shape of size n, right?
You just fill in the
nodes top down until you
get to the last level.
And then you have to fill
them in left to right.
It's what you might call reading
order for writing down nodes.
And the array is telling
you which keys go where.
This is the first node you
write down at the root,
this is the next
node you write down
at the left child of
the root, and so on.
So here we have a binary
tree represented as an array,
or array representing
a binary tree.
The very specific
binary tree, it
has a clear advantage, which
is it is guaranteed balance.
No rotations necessary in heaps,
because complete binary trees
are always balanced.
In fact, they have the best
height they possibly could,
which is ceiling of log n.
Balanced, remember, just
meant you were big O of log n.
This is 1 times log n.
So it's the best level of
balance you could hope for.
So somehow, I claim, we can
maintain a complete binary tree
for solving priority queues.
This would not be
possible if you
were trying to solve
the whole set interface.
And that's kind of the
cool thing about heaps,
is that by just focusing on the
subset of the set interface,
we can do more.
We can maintain this
very strong property.
And because we have this
very strong property,
we don't even need
to store this tree.
We're not going to store left
and right pointers and parent
pointers, we're just
going to store the array.
This is what we call an
implicit data structure, which
basically means no pointers,
just an array of the n items.
How are we going to get away
without storing pointers?
I'd still like to
treat it like a tree.
I'd still like to know
the left child of B is D
and the right child B is E.
We'll see why in a moment.
Well, we can do this
with index arithmetic.
So maybe I should add some
labels before I get there.
So this array
naturally has indices.
This is index 0.
This is index 1, index 2, index
3, index 4, index 5, index 6,
7, 8, 9, because there
are 10 items, 0 through 9.
And I can apply those
labels up here, too.
These are the same
nodes, so 0, 1, 2.
This is just a depth order.
But once I have
this labeling, it's
going to be a lot easier
to figure things out.
So if I wanted to know
the left child of B is D,
somehow, given the number 1, I
want to compute the number 3.
Add 2, there are all
sorts-- multiply by 3,
there are all
sorts of operations
that take 1 and turn it into 3.
But there's only one that's
going to work in all cases.
And the intuition here
is, well, I have to 2
the i nodes at level i.
If I want to go to
the child level,
there's 2 to the i plus
1 nodes down there--
exactly double.
So it's the very last one,
but that won't really matter.
If there is a left child,
it will behave the same.
And so, intuitively, I have
this space of size 2 to the i.
I have to expand it to a space
of size 2 to the i plus 1,
So I should multiply by 2.
And that's almost right, but
then there's some constants.
So I'd like to say 2 times i.
But if we look at the
examples here, 1 times 2
is 2, which is 1 less than 3.
2 times 2 is 4, which
is 1 less than 5.
Hey, we almost got it right.
It's just off by 1.
Off by 1 is--
index errors are the most common
things in computer science.
What about the right child?
If the left child is a 2i plus
1, where is the right child?
I hear lots of mumbles.
2i plus 2-- one more.
Because we're writing things
left to right in depth order,
the right child is the right
sibling of the left child.
So it's just one larger, OK?
Given those rules, we
can also compute parent.
It's just whatever
is the inverse
of both of these
functions, which I want
to divide by 2 at some point.
I want to get back to i given
2i plus 1 or given 2i plus 2.
And so if I subtract 1
from i, then I either
get 2i or 2i plus 1.
And then, if I take an integer
division by 2, I get i--
the original i.
Sorry, maybe I'll call
this j to be clearer.
So j is the left or right child.
Then I can reconstruct
i, which was the parent.
So this is constant number
arithmetic operations.
So I don't have to store
left and right pointers.
I can just compute them
whenever I need them.
Whenever I'm at
some node like E,
and I want to know
what's its left child--
sorry, given the
node index 4, which
happens to contain
the item E, and I
want to know what's its left
child, I just multiply by 2
and add 1.
I get 9.
And then, I can index into
this array at position 9.
Because I don't-- this is
just in my head, remember.
We're just thinking that
there's a tree here.
But in reality, on the computer,
there's just the array.
So if we want to go from E
to J, we can, from 4 to 9.
If we go try to go to the
right child, we multiply by 2.
8 add 2-- 10.
And we see, oh, 10 is
beyond the end of the array.
But our array stores its
size, so we realize, oh, E
does not have a right child.
This is something you can only
do in a complete binary tree.
In a general binary
tree you don't
have these nice properties.
Cool, so this is
basically a heap.
I just need to add
one more property,
naturally called
the heap property.
So there are multiple
types of heaps.
This type of heap is
called a binary heap.
We will talk about others
in future lectures.
I'm going to call it
Q. Explicit thing--
this is an array representing
a complete binary tree,
called the array Q. And we
want every node to satisfy
the so-called max-heap property,
which says Q[i] is greater than
or equal to Q[j] for both
children left of i and right
of i.
So we have a node i.
And it has two children--
2i plus 1 and 2i plus 2.
These are two values of j.
What we want is a
greater than or equal to
relation here and here.
So this node should be
bigger than both this one
and this one.
Which of these is larger?
We don't know, and
we don't care--
very different from
binary search trees
or set binary trees, where we
said these guys were less than
or equal to this one,
this one was less than
or equal to all the nodes
in the subtree here.
We're just locally
saying, this node
is greater than or equal
to this node and this node.
So the biggest is at the top.
So one nice lemma about
these heaps-- this is weird.
Let me give you
some more intuition.
If you are a binary heap, if you
satisfy this max-heap property
everywhere, then
in fact, you learn
that every node i is greater
than or equal to all nodes
in its subtree.
These are what we call
descendants in subtree of i.
Let me look at this example.
So I haven't written
any numbers here.
You can imagine.
So A here is greater than
or equal to both B and C,
and B is greater than
or equal to D and E,
and C is greater than
or equal to F and G,
D is greater than
or equal to H and I,
and E is greater
than or equal to J.
That would make this
structure a heap,
not just a complete binary tree.
So what does that imply?
It implies that A
must be the maximum.
So you look at any
node here, like J, A
is greater than or equal to B
is greater than or equal to E
is greater than or equal to
J. And in general, what we're
saying is that A is greater
than or equal to all nodes
in the tree.
B is greater than or equal
to all nodes in its subtree
down here.
C is greater than or equal
to all nodes in its subtree.
That's what this
lemma is saying.
You can prove this
lemma by induction.
But it's really simple.
If you have two nodes, i
and j, and j is somewhere
in the subtree,
that means there's
some downward path from i to j.
And you know that,
for every edge
we traverse on a
downward path, our key
is going down non-strictly.
So every child is less than
or equal to its parent.
i is greater than
or equal to this,
is greater than
or equal to j, OK?
So by transitivity of
less than or equal to,
you know that i is, in fact,
greater than or equal to j.
Or sorry, the key
in i is greater than
or equal to the key in j.
This is what we're
calling i, the index.
This is what we
would call Q of i.
This is Index j Q of j.
Very different way to
organize keys in a tree,
but as you might
imagine, this is going
to be good for priority queues.
Because priority
queues just need
to find the maximum elements.
Then they need to delete it.
That's going to be harder,
because leading the root
is, like-- that's the hardest
node to delete, intuitively.
I'd really prefer
to delete leaves.
But leading leaves and
keeping a complete binary tree
is actually kind of hard.
If I want to delete
H, that doesn't
look like a binary
tree, or it doesn't
look like a complete
binary tree anymore.
It's not left justified.
Similarly, if I want to
delete F, that's bad.
Because now, I don't
have four nodes here.
The one node that's easy
to delete is J, right?
If I remove that node, I
still have a complete tree.
The last leaf, the last
position in my array,
is the one that's
easy to delete.
That's good, because arrays are
good at leading the last item.
But what I've set up here is
it's easy to find the max.
It's going to be up
here at the root.
Deleting it is annoying.
I'd like to somehow take that
key and put it at position--
at the last position
at the last leaf,
because that's the one
that's easy to delete.
And that's indeed
what we're going
to do in a delete algorithm.
Let me first do insert.
I guess that's a little
simpler, kind of symmetric
to what we just said.
So if I want to insert a key or
an item x which has some key,
again, the only thing I
really can do in an array--
if I want to add a new item,
it has to go at the end.
The only thing we
know how to do is
insert at the end of an array.
This is what we
called insert_last.
this?
Corresponds to adding
a node containing x--
the item x-- in the very last
level of the complete binary
tree.
Either it goes to the right
of all the existing nodes,
or starts a new level.
But it's always going
to be the last leaf.
After we do the
insertion, it will be
at position size of Q minus 1.
This is probably
not enough, though.
We just inserted an
arbitrary item in a leaf.
And now, it may not satisfy
the max-heap property anymore.
So let's just check if it does,
and if it doesn't, fix it.
That's what we know how to do.
But this time,
we're not even going
to need rotations,
which is cool.
So I'm going to define
an operation called
max_heapify_up.
This will make things
more like a max-heap.
We're going to start at size
of Q minus 1 for our value i.
But it's going to be recursive,
so what we're going to do
is look at a node i,
in particular the one
that just got inserted.
And where could
it violate things?
Well, with its parent, because
we have no idea what key
we just put here.
Maybe it's less than our parent.
Then we're happy.
But if it's greater than
our parent, we're in trouble
and we should fix it.
So if the item in the parent's
key is less than i's key--
ah, I see I forgot to write
key and all these spots.
This should be dot
key and dot key,
because Q[i] is an
item that gets its key.
So this is the bad case.
This is if the parent is
smaller than the child.
We wanted the parent
to always be greater
than or equal to its children.
So in that case,
what could we do?
Swap them.
Let's swap Q parent of i--
excellent, more
chalk-- with Q[i].
Now they're in the right order.
Now, we need to think about
what about the other child
of that node?
And what about its parent?
So I have some numbers here.
Let's say this was
5 and this was 10.
What do I know about
this picture before?
Well, I know that 10 is
this newly inserted item.
It's the only one that
could have caused violations
when I first inserted it.
So I know that before this--
before I moved 10 around,
I knew all the things
in this left subtree
are less than or equal to
5, and everything up here
are created equal to 5.
I also know that the nodes in
here, in fact, were less than
or equal to 5.
Other than this node 10
that we just inserted,
this was a correct heap.
So 5 was a separator between--
things above it on
the ancestor chain
are greater than or equal to
5, and things in its subtree
are less than or equal to it.
So after I do this swap,
which I'm just going to do--
after I swap the items 5 and
10, 10 is up here, 5 is here.
And now, I realize,
OK, great, this edge
is happy, because now 10 is
greater than or equal to 5.
But also this edge is happy,
because it used to be happy,
and we only made
its parent larger.
Now this edge maybe is bad.
And so we need to recurse--
recurse on the parent.
But that's it.
So we fixed this one edge.
Initially, this happens
way down at the leaf.
But in general,
we're taking our item
that we inserted, which is x,
and it starts at the last leaf,
and it may be bubbles
up for a while.
And maybe it gets all
the way to the root
if we inserted a
new maximum item.
But in each step,
it goes up one.
And so the running
time of all this stuff
is the height of the
tree, which is log n.
And because there's only this
one item that could potentially
be wrong, if it
ever stops moving,
we've just checked
that it satisfies
the max-heap property.
If it gets to the
root, you can also
check it satisfies
the max-heap property.
So there's a base case
I didn't write here,
which is if i equals 0, we're
at the root, we're done.
And then you can prove
this correct by induction.
There's just one item that's
in the wrong spot, initially.
And we put it into a right spot.
There are many places it could
go, but we will move it to the,
I guess, unique ancestor
position that is correct--
that satisfies
max-heap property, OK?
So that's insert.
Delete is going to be almost
the same, delete_min, that is--
sorry, delete_max, thank you.
You can of course define
all of these things
for min instead of max.
Everything works the same.
I just have a hard
time remembering
which one we're doing.
Just don't switch you can't use
a max-heap to do delete_min.
You can't use a min-heap
to do delete_max,
but you can use a
min-heap to do delete_min.
That's fine.
So like I said, the only node
we really know how to delete
is the last leaf
on the last level,
which is the end of the array.
Because that's what arrays
can delete efficiently.
And what we need to
delete is the root item,
because that's always
the maximum one, which
is at the first
position in the array.
So what do we do?
Swap them, our usual trick.
I think the cool
thing about heaps
is we never have
to do rotations.
We're only going to do
swaps, which is something
we had to do with trees also--
binary trees.
Q[0] with Q of the last item--
great, done.
Now we have the last item is
the one we want to delete.
So we do delete_last, or pop in
Python, and boom, we've got--
we've now deleted
the maximum item.
Of course, we may have also
messed up the max-heap property
just like we did with insert.
So with insert, we were
adding a last leaf.
Now, what we're doing is
swapping the last leaf
with the--
I'm pointing at
the wrong picture.
Let me go back to this tree.
What we did is swap item J
with A. So the problem is now--
and then we deleted this node.
The problem is now
that that root node
has maybe a very small key.
Because the key that's here
now is whatever was down here,
which is very low in the tree.
So intuitively,
that's a small value.
This is supposed to
be the maximum value,
and we just put a small
value in the root.
So what do we do?
Heapify down.
We're going to take that
item and somehow push it
down to the tree until the--
down in the tree until
max-heap property is satisfied.
So this is going to
be max_heapify_down.
And we will start at position
0, which is the root.
And max_heapify_down is going
to be a recursive algorithm.
So we'll start at
some position i.
And initially, that's the root.
And what we're going to do is
look at position i and its two
children.
So let's say we put a very
small value up here, like 0.
And let's say we have
our children, 5 and 10.
We don't know-- maybe
I'll swap their order just
to be more generic, because
that looks like not quite
a binary search
tree, but we don't
know their relative order.
But one of them is greater
than or equal to the other
in some order.
And so what would I like to
do to fix this local picture?
Yeah, I want to swap.
And I could swap--
0 is clearly in the wrong spot.
It needs to go
lower in the tree.
I can swap 0 with
5 or 0 with 10.
Which one?
10.
I could draw the picture with
5, but it will not be happy.
Why 10?
We want to do it
with the larger one,
because then this
edge will be happy,
and also this edge
will be happy.
If I swapped 5 up there instead,
the 5/10 edge would be unhappy.
It wouldn't satisfy
the max-heap property.
So I can do one swap and
fix max-heap property.
Except that, again, 0 may be
unhappy with its children.
0 was this one item that
was in the wrong spot.
And so it made it have
to go farther down.
But 5 will be--
5 didn't even move.
So it's happy.
Everything in this
subtree is good.
What about the parent?
Well, if you think about
it, because everything
was a correct heap
before we added 0,
or before we put 0 too
high, all of these nodes
will be greater than or equal
to 10 on the ancestor path.
And all of these nodes were
less than or equal to 10
before, unless
you're equal to 5.
So that's still true.
But you see, this tree is happy.
This tree still may be unhappy.
0 still might need
to push down farther.
That's going to
be the recursion.
So we check down here.
There's a base case, which is
if i is a leaf, we're done.
Because there's
nothing below them.
So we satisfy the
max-heap property at i
because there's no children.
Otherwise, let's look at
the leaf among the left--
sorry, left not leaf--
among the two children
left and right of i.
Right if i might not exist.
Then ignore it.
But among the two
children that exist,
find the one that has
maximum key value, Q[j].key.
That was 10 in our example.
And then, if these
items are out of order,
if we do not satisfy--
so greater than
would be satisfy.
Less than Q[j] would be the
opposite of the max-heap
property here.
If max-heap property
is violated,
then we fix it by
swapping Q[i] with Q[j],
and then we recurse on j--
call max_heapify_down of j.
That's it.
So pretty symmetric.
Insert was a little bit
simpler, because we only
have one parent.
Delete_min, because
we're pushing down,
we have two children.
We have to pick one.
But there's a clear
choice-- the bigger one.
And again, this algorithm--
this whole thing--
will take order h time,
the height of the tree,
which is log n, because our
node just sort of bubbles down.
At some point, it stops.
When it stops, we know
the max-heap property
was satisfied there.
And if you check along
the way, by induction,
all the other
max-heap properties
will be satisfied,
because they were before.
So almost forced what
we could do here.
The amazing thing is
that you can actually
maintain a complete
binary tree that satisfies
the max-heap property.
But once you're told that, the
algorithm kind of falls out.
Because we have an array.
The only thing we can
do is insert and delete
the last item.
And so we've got to swap
things to there in order--
or out of there in
order to make that work.
And then, the rest is
just checking locally
that you can fix the property.
Cool.
So that's almost it, not
quite what we wanted.
So we now have log n amortize
insert and delete_max
in our heap.
We did not yet
cover linear build.
Right now, it's n log n
if you insert n times.
And we did not yet cover how to
make this an in-place sorting
algorithm.
So let me sketch each of those.
I think first is in-place.
So how do we make this
algorithm in-place?
I guess I want that,
but I don't need this.
So we want to follow
priority queue sort.
Maybe I do want that.
But I don't want to have to
grow and shrink my array.
I would just like to start
with the array itself.
So this is in place.
So what we're going to
do is say, OK, here's
my array that I want to sort.
That's given to me.
That's the input to
priority queue sort.
And what I'd like is to build
a priority queue out of it.
Initially, it's empty.
And then I want to insert the
items one at a time, let's say.
So in general, what
I'm going to do
is maintain that Q
is some prefix of A.
That's going to be
my priority queue.
It's going to live in this
sub array-- this prefix.
So how do I insert a new item?
Well, I just increment.
So to do an insert, the first
step is increment size of Q.
Then I will have taken
the next item from A
and injected into this Q.
And conveniently, if we look at
our insert code, which is here,
the first thing we wanted
to do was add an item
at the end of the array.
So we just did it without
any actual work, just
conceptual work.
We just said, oh,
our Q is one bigger.
Boom!
Now this is at the
end of the array.
no more amortization, in
fact, because we're not ever
resizing our array,
we're just saying, oh,
now Q is a little bit
bigger of a prefix.
It just absorb the
next item of A.
Similarly, delete_max
is going to,
at the end, decrement the
size of Q. Why is that OK?
Because at the end of our
delete_max operation--
not quite at the end,
but almost the end--
we deleted the last
item from our array.
So we just replaced that
delete last with a decrement,
and that's going to
shrink the Q by 1.
It has the exact same impact
as leading the last item.
But now, it's constant time,
worst case not amortized.
And the result is we never
actually build a dynamic array.
We just use a portion
of A to do it.
So what's going
to happen is we're
going to absorb all the items
into the priority queue,
and then start kicking them out.
As we kick them out, we kick
out the largest key item first,
and we put it here, then
the next largest, then
the next largest, and so on.
The minimum item is
going to be here.
And, boom, it's sorted.
This is the whole reason I did
max-heaps instead of min-heaps,
is that in the end, this
will be a upward sorted array
with the max at the end.
Because we always kick
out items at the end.
We delete the max first.
So that is what's
normally called heapsort.
You can apply this same trick
to insertion sort and selection
sort, and you actually get the
insertion sort and selection
sort algorithms that
we've seen which operate
in prefixes of the array.
Cool, so now we have--
we've achieved the
y up there, which
is n log n sorting
algorithm that is in-place.
So that was our main goal--
heapsort.
Let me very quickly mention you
can build a heap in linear time
with a clever trick.
So if you insert the
items one at a time,
that would correspond to
inserting down the array.
And every time I insert an item,
I have to walk up the tree.
So this would be the sum
of the depth of each node.
If you do that, you get n log n.
This is the sum over i of log i.
That turns out to be n log n.
It's a log of n factorial.
The cool trick is
to, instead, imagine
adding all the items
at once and not
heapifying anything, and
then heapify up-- sorry,
heapify down from the bottom up.
So here we're heapifying up.
Now, we're going
to heapify down.
And surprisingly, that's better.
Because this is the sum of
the heights of the nodes.
And that turns out to be linear.
It's not obvious.
But intuitively, for a depth,
this is 0, this is log n,
and we've got a
whole ton of leaves.
So right at the leaf level, you
can see, we're paying n log n,
right?
Because there are n of them,
and each one costs log n.
Down here, at the leaf
level, we're paying constant.
Because the height
of the leaves are 1.
Here, the height of
the root is log n.
And this is better.
Now we're paying a small
amount for the thing
of which there are many.
It's not quite a
geometric series,
but it turns out this is linear.
So that's how you can
do linear building heap.
To come back to your question
about sequence AVL trees,
turns out you can get
all of the same bounds
as heaps, except for
the in-place part,
by taking a sequence
AVL tree, storing
the items in an arbitrary
order, and augmenting
by max, which is a crazy idea.
But it also gives you
a linear build time.
And yeah, there's other
fun stuff in your notes.
But I'll stop there.